Michelle Obama
is complaining
not exactly a major breaking news
headline Michelle Obama does nothing but
complain
but Michelle Obama is complaining this
time about how
when her husband was elected president
Americans were not ready
for her natural hair
I don't know what Michelle Obama's
natural hair looks like I I truly
couldn't possibly care less what
Michelle Obama's natural hair looks like
uh Michelle Obama was giving an
interview to Ellen DeGeneres
this was reported by the independent we
don't have a clip of it we do have the
quote
she said let me keep my hair straight
let's get health care passed first they
tripped out when Barack wore a tan suit
you know the great indignity the scandal
of the Obama Administration is when
Barack wore a tan suit
so there everyone was on edge to
criticize Obama and she just said I
don't know if I can wear my natural hair
the code of ethics at a workplace as
black women we deal with it the whole
thing about do you show up with your
natural hair I would get my staff all
worried too I was like I was thinking
about getting braids that's the
African-American experience but women in
offices that are worried should I wear
skirts should I wear pantyhose I hate
pantyhose but when you're carrying all
this other stuff this mask
these differences and you're trying to
do your job it's just an extra burden
on overcoming
so I'm going to get out now you know I
know some people like it when I play
ukulele or sometimes guitar so I'm just
going to pull out
there it is
the world's tiniest little Stradivarius
violin just
there we go just just play that out for
burdens of Michelle Obama to overcome
the completely
absurdly perceived stigma again about
how she wears her hair
the people of the United States
had just elected her husband
Barack Hussein Obama
to be the president of the United States
we had been at war
against at least initially a man named
Hussein for uh
five years at that point
and really actually much longer U.S
policy against Saddam Hussein had gone
back to the early 90s and
we are told that what the American
people just were not ready for it was
Michelle Obama's here Barack Obama wore
his natural hair by the way first black
president
no it was but it's all about Michelle
and it's all America elected the first
black president but no there's still
evil and racist the American people they
gave Michelle Obama an absolute fairy
tale life no they're still it's so awful
for her it's so terrible this is the
burden of overcoming this is what black
people this is what makes their lives so
difficult you know do you show up with
natural hair now
I defer to the black listeners of this
show
is that that's the biggest problem in
your life
how to wear your what hairstyle to have
at the office I bet not
I bet not when I think about
long conversations with my black friends
I they don't usually bring up
how to wear their hair as the biggest
challenge they have real problems
Michelle Obama doesn't have any real
problems and so she has to make up
problems because
the Obamas like the libs broadly
cannot take a yes for an answer
they can't take yes for an answer
it's there's always got to be a problem
there racism will never go away it can't
go away
according to the libs because that's
that's the premise they're starting from
they need it
okay oppressured
suffering
all these things look evil never never
will go away not until not during this
period of earth right not until the
second coming we're not we're not going
to say this is a Fallen World okay so
there's always going to be evil and
suffering and the good way to react to
evil and suffering is with a spirit of
resignation and uh with virtue and so
that you can allow suffering to sanctify
you this was a line I think was from
Saint Jose Maria escriva who said never
say that person annoys me say oh that
person sanctifies me
we're all going to be going at
Thanksgiving to visit our family maybe
you've got a difficult family maybe you
got some you know sibling or cousin or
in-law or something that drives you
crazy no you that person doesn't annoy
you that person sanctifies you
and if you cultivate that attitude I
promise you it doesn't matter how
terrible
the the suffering is
you will be buoyant we talked about this
earlier I guess it was last week with
Jay Leno Jay Leno just suffered horrible
Burns but he's buoyant he bounced right
back he was giving out cookies to the
kids in the in the hospital he was he
was being treated at okay if you
cultivate those virtues
no no amount of suffering is going to
keep you down for very long
if you don't if all you do is cultivate
resentment and envy and anger and all
the stuff that Michelle Obama does
then no amount of privilege will ever
make you feel happy you can be the first
lady of the United States and you will
still be angry about how you in your
fantasies your hair might be perceived
okay there is no limit to the things
that you will complain about
you if you cultivate those things we get
you know hap Vice and virtue are habits
okay and you and you get what you do and
what you cultivate the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss
this okay if you are not a member click
the link in the description and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]